So here we are in front of the palace, just about to go in.
I've got my periodic table tie, so we're
ready to go.
So we're inside the palace, still got the tie,
we're about to go inside.
No filming inside by us, but I'll tell you what happens afterwards.
Professor Sir Martin Poliakoff
for services to the chemical sciences.
So it was really good, I spoke to Prince Charles,
he asked me about how the green chemistry was going.
I told him that we were making anti-malerial
drugs, and that we're now doing green chemistry.
We hope to demonstrate using light to induce chemical reactions.
He seemed very interested.
Said he'd like to visit.
When I first got my doctorates and was
called Doctor Poliakoff
the only reason that I found the
doctorate useful
was to complain in shops.
If you telephoned and said look you, this is not right.
If you said it was Doctor Poliakoff it produced an effect.
Now I have no idea
whether 'Sir' will produce an effect, similar effect,
or whether people will just laugh.
Here we are, outside the palace taking photographs.
And here is the knighthood medal.
I'm quite excited.
And it doesn't look as if it's pure gold,
but it clearly has some gold in it.